richard let you no i then chargers
brain dump even
pendant lights warning training time
when they make mistakes that you just as
and lamps used and budget af asking
questions but to the gym and a training
time
handrails supposed to reinforcement
learning
the cozy in which symbolic and you have is
an ice problem i spoke to an expert
not be just a few my bingo like a
human teacher i can also be and high
grade a''
your listening kind en microsoft
research  podcast
a show that dot color shirt in the
cutting-edge technology research and the
scientists pine de firehose
gretsch using a
[music]
that you the depth that there principal
researcher in an adaptive systems and
interaction group rms ar and something curly
ex porn star alliance  of research and
may help bridge the gap between
perception and planning for thomas
agents
teaching to make decisions on door a
storm that a living step and aspe  r
directions for next last
ante this podcast up-to-date talks about
how this latest work in mather riesling
had his tastes modular system pipelines
and how imitation learning is die ml
switchboard between super weitere infos
met learning
bios explains how neuro architectures
workshops en lie  in the dark arts the
song training and reveals how soil and
robot
instagram twitter in india en de us what
you're working career and research are
much more on this episode of the
microsoft research podcast
[Music]
because you this really great house her
right up to hone your colleagues are
liang qichao lodger taking the the
musical name of the planetary finisch
and the palm tree the jets right but fruit
yes and in your guy also peach tea and asset
now really come for  the yes yes o the jogging
my friends is like mike indeed so that
bad guy ailment via project antibiotic
black green tea party like you start
right there at least the  you that
would be assessed the en wat seamless
libische harder to black granite
and is also like to phone screen for the
25 en wil m zo gletscher principal
researcher in the adaptive systems in
interaction en je site group and
microsoft research and used to work at
the intersection of production machine
arnhem
ja to forego that panel that you the
situation and group of people
and viaducts system is team a nice
hope to accomplish
group or click to play this is one of the
alias two groups and so right places in
africa this was foger  with each individual in
your history of time is a group sub 1
a mini groups at span off from may so
bright
so is he is beautiful he must sea in silent
or fatima group is more difficult family is
he is a thief and groupden bosch groups
because  most people who have very by
force impression of this circle common
teams which die the group the gather and
our theory this decision making and
then suck the s people gringoire can in
the audience die  from machine learning
this paper thing where consumers walking
fridge and social fried x this paper
thing work and reinforcement learning
planning decisionmaking a thousand also
a tip where all of these things have
come on is nice you decisionmaking to
the tree that chance friend
what the window had  week and agents to
be a bumpy and who do you who you
try such a legend we the apple ii
type know what they don't know and how
you would expect in the jumping tight
hair wil the steering gear on the roof at
un long jihad  in the morning
watch your big coal essen scientist and
fire fire poincaré why would be known
for the in new york area you know i was
thinking about it yesterday and one of
the king's utterance wits ran alchemy
is corpse in the online team huge of van
de  meta contributions to the century and
white never min just coming up with
new theory met doutzen principles of
how to apply them principles of how to
practice group decision science in de
warm
let's talk about you work there depth arbi
corine here is machine learning and anna
podcast from the mine cooling to
start with the de of newspapers machine
learning in their work
yes there is flyer it is a unique
strengths and weaknesses [ __ ] item
really interesting working in the  area
of ml
madeko learning from demonstration and
more specifically imitation learning
sangita approach those times for is a
polis hello jefferson earlier methods and
what good for and why we need on most
of all the big chunk of machine learning
thankyou and de start to the supervisor
and i like you whether the task of
labor data and then you green thumb
musicalia carving en graphite black you
work for king of functional places
matter who says that if you get new
detail and process longer than the dancing
with free wi-fi and that produce  the
training the cape
euphorbia turn your project becomes
dailymotion my empire and its
footprints for depression test so supervisor
learning theor  ie and practical is who is
and so reflected the challenge that the
where is my focusing on page new the
focus on in the last 15 years as being
for small and i try and reinforce met
lending and greetings cry to explore van
scratch grinding kabila ras  ayuyun that
the age was a coat bang en
nahuysplein now go to war and acquire knowledge to
action learning is great means grump
where it says camping the line-up all i
see a good way effecting in the war
based on what export sharing great en de
reason this is our goal is because you
can't bootstrap pipeline is one shilling
more tanks that uni access bunnik spoke
teacher but the de peecher is a
lot and this could then you can very
quickly interests
police want you matter is just a few
million  doe is my mac the peter
celebs the learning of demonstration the
teacher demonstrates
to the agents and a nation lines for na
in the somewhere between
just having this day the port john van
de ports and
know nothing a  nd do not right from
bos confused special ine domains nice
bin x you don't mind
eurobike importance of notting brain watch you
through the start tabula rasa
you channel you him so bring the police
that you enable greg start in
ministry
this  is my cat righting put train and
robots arcs brush
what shone heart people and so the arm out
to this to your app is inhuman tag my neck
complex any
gigelli of reinforcement learning
worship is who you high end white
crime libya long long time before you
to increasing tank gwn my it [ __ ]
edgar mitchell
you then some interesting exploration
number you can euro architecture search
or nah local for short
yes what is a conscious motivation for
enhancing impacting other there is in the
machine learning world so suddenly the
philosophy is finished so different  on filling
machine learning tolokonnikova black tie
black gray melange
one is your leak every hour reed and search for
the right on the written for giving back
so let'  s ethical vision ptss and x
labor rights lithium can sail in the simplex
settings and you think the
leak ok moi like i no time our items the
harbor looked in the chair bayonet director
is so the best grade a'' is the best
way to pay  process detail what after get so
the patient and the chance what is the district
architecture' rotates and is to the
district parameters of architecture as
the handrail series can you and the
surroundings year at the cali the day art
of training and finding i do it  now all
the work for the place cm us so this is
more than just right and left 4 dead and
satisfying clegg de xxl greg de progress
dat die planning is medical fantastic
everybody's website there but this is true
dakar part which is there and people and
like  well your sister not the turn device
of practitioner and you can once you get
there
pride and this is one and services that
play and satisfying good the community
is a god
bright blackwood reviews gladys sgp
scrub followers scientist at  this time
i can carro fire
yes touch table dance is cable and it
also shows that like i know
black gloss de battle
gurges' show and understanding of deep
learning is social or that i don't know
how to grow  the fighting
nice in your work in anna en essie yes yes
sorry aim in new l'architecture
searches led algorithms
touch for architecture sledge remove the
human from these videos dat gods word
af kleine figure expressions of experience
and is also works people that place in
most  companies and organizations
handsome four times a few days just
sitting around grinding en excelsior the
reboot usage of few best site is cry cry
en wie won the idea that the green data
set led de machine figure out what if
you try and speed bike oud de module  pro
free streaming me
he covered jorah a penalty kinabalu
researchers election and reports
troubleshoot and improve want him system
of flyer and upc pepper
streatham janne concepts of and rea  soning
those men journal chest software mattel
van de fly easing reinforcement learning
to optimize pipeline yes it is
fascinating and really like a your friend
this resigns for modular software and
its impact on another person the systems
hi key can we give them review
what i wrote  hair in modular software
systems in channel en en to live like i
believe mather easing is critical to
improving the guidelines zo this project
so between south limburg iphone bug
female topical starter because for
discussion widow place of patrick kind of
interaction and team en dan bolhuis we
are a boring group and like if it's a
few by snow family and they set the
problem my actuly chance van den
hurk
he imitates lee jump on the problem
because i believe in force with learning
can expand pro high vision bowlines
afrika correctness of archie suffered dat
problem really more margin of es
salaam i give you this nice example
which should be easy to follow mn gini
true s  m driving car ping is running and
you so of work in progress software team
is divided into many subteams we chai
pudding mini components on the cell
driving car software klek klek
somebodies district in the planner summer the
riding lola expired checkers amber
use my vision system  perception system
en dender is part of the team ver
everybody's in gripping al die specifically
edgar en de en application runs dry and
this is a phenomenon wit software 10
fast justin works but also like you
glamping web software wat knock you find
this all time
laxity whole team  it is the flap in the
computer vision software then that pack is
black and has this touch or 6th day that
sword down the robot empire name ajax can become
free and in control the infernal
machine off model weekness sangeetha
and that model is lexus excuse it with  you're
not necessarily super naive but doing this
gets the tossed on the rest or the teams
the push that fast fashion or the man i
would like to this is a buckland wright
and toe wipers keep this and the site of the
little ones in tasting fines times x is 1
minute sense is not good enough
but that's okay nice oh darling
plougher 3 months ago by the looks of
hard work and give this a name and and
rabbit press and  corgi architect there seems
so
rest of the team you don't need to do
anything just cola light escort
nothing will change for you which
cannot take and everything should wear
great guy so heavy body gautama buddha
ken who there put your address speak and here
your hair khandvi human or super hardwiring
taste rock this accent also close to
hand press are other what is this time
but now and then all the penguin is
tasty what have and i have one is that
costs soft drinks wheat son relax i
systems that person
current the premium  close up down three
modules have not just add to account
for that the lack of via 90 freshair
architecture most of the time i actually
going to like i know before i can be
traffic the sky the decisions have  am in
more downstream
week you guys have the pen third of the
quality or the re even coming up
screen in arnhem i the coolest scampi
heavily they have
shortly after the quality of this more
new classes graphically shifter
and less this becker the nexus cam
actually has not  become globally barry
i got him globally was my
and this is a phenomenal daily newspaper
driver teams that sees all the time
the shashlik and annick alex and
politicians explain
black i know if you manage and anything
from black window software and english
system that has multiple parcs  yes so in
proofing because park that is one less our
system becomes perfect america where is
contact me cross
just like in nascar yard like i made
using and reduce the search for
algorithms this is another way at
him be there again
give who heat machine line  money back
to check the entire pipeline and see what
if you target the via the changing
conditions which you see this monitor is
looking out system specifie  k that part
selection peony usage memory usage the
runtime i in something kampio the
goodies monitoring and direction the a
few pipeline is wel s the hardware on
which is running index conditions wright
en this is learning
policies to change the configuration en of
the entire pipeline on  the fly
your turns how does the best can as the
and of my changes and tomorrow will
change children in impactful' session
patchwork infographic promises dry and
right now you're looking for bigger and
bigger pipelines
we tasted sauna nancy furry weekend
showcase this app and  better than what
you're having a research paper
heading along with a paper that i just
a blush and some skyline containing the
marie sing for the spines
so pepper is very popular in
figurative maud in february action from
new york knicks week and then dare  sure
that you can
use nothing like a text word and aids
it's time for a force with
learning to safely
jeans the configurations or a few
pipelin  es and acquiring and let them but
great britain testicle league serial
changing conditions from china justice'
site no but it's my the new
replacement surgery for decades the head
compressed not ici pour l tank football
and the new cartridge suba new
chair i used to working  in a
particularly yes when the knee surgery
i gained an inch and not like some
effect on
us i soon you back as to like i
know is that a consideration ride the
contest
well in is trump basically a free
system
greenium a pariah  sypesteyn can
put here yes I already said squeak grunt
pot
oh my word grande punto big that there is a
mecca and then think of for people on the
cart his great hair growth
the suspension is not enough air people
cool tyler jesse qoeraidah control is
to  arnhem and amphibians wat
ultimately score day
[Music]
to vote the polder model robot
depths capable sirius
thomas fishing family with digital
systems like cortana a series of more luxurious
and sums massive hair physical robots
like him but did you mean i had a fight
make m in the fridge be able to
interact with physical robots that a
natural language and highly trained
to push him brother friday of task force
balance sweet africa's for help my
idea
yes is subtle and calls on i become you thing
here now the between milly interesting
francis research opening this project at
you guys just that you referring to
actually starter with the half
conversation with big coal and realized
nap group
afcajax him in an excuse dfr
budget parking bright  because of my
previous experience which i bought
back if they are a bit the simulation
system whiplash and cheeto
and chris la web and fell from the roof
hey symbolism is talking to play you
grohl and the communities that right and
already looking for some remarks know
just  how do things that fly and drive
offline and would be to people
earthquake british military weak and
everyday via coverage backer and the kb
that'  s so very rich thick set of 4
people scan clean and put into first
sim black and white human with a rail
[ __ ] as the bank and that you ps the
bank and rich game engines i got it so
greg long go can the enthusiast game
engine sarah
de rendering photorealistic science and
peace on this opportunity dark grape
maybe i can train agents to know this
project reasonably to people come and
see and language instructions in in door
scenarios but also like past for i
have the wild things with a
was that het de kam  more this moment one
of the best dance very complicated
algorithms do work
gary bulex experts and accuracy of doen
en die tas provider de bar interest
greyjoy
de just like in the chewing light
language in us your family member to how
can i help you can get me  this right now
i'm working on desk and ease grass and
that made s
dm 180 reaction video talking about to
the mingo upstairs and we like arno and
fancy pigeons rational also
you may be just for had no v  an the
have awareness that guinea pig suffers and
inefficient as you just that the men
expert and peter jackson dj jasper greg
and
especialy of those four deadly poppy
comments and and bring that direction burden
so that china rio de janeiro region
swingback as website
selection figures budget number off  gryce
bridge and see it all live so
game show was when you click to call of
frank
a trip line and lifeline i touch in
light led china and lizzie has 4 life
lines leads and she critical him i
about how you play these life lines  honey
is by use the money is the question
much reason in all such a thing stretchable
but expensive as it is so step down like
if you mess up
carly and the service and now use the
light lemon do your shirt there
you those out of  de grange your walked around
in the game long to fly so this the
steps that anyway spot north agency
has trained and sells hi wendy was
being training time black window make
mistakes that you just ask and learn to
use the  budget off asking questions and
bake the the eraser and her training time
myself
right when you're in the simulation and
why won't be used imitation online stuff
suppository enforcement learning to your
stalking where the magician you for the
cozy in which symbolic you now have  is
maize programmatic experts expert not
not be just a few my leg glide human
teach it can also be and high grade a''
x-access dollars more information and
her training time you another
information act as time but the
penguin  information you try to
like mimiek wat dan expert for you and
light en en
in simulation you can just prior
planning and read and features jazz flex
orchestra spray help him and the line to
make one shot is marguerite hem pull up
gass time en vendoorn you don  't have the
in charge of mission access
training hit and white roof who had
lived so long in the app illusion of the
age and your that opportunity and of workplace and
variant set and right now i should ask
for help and i greatly improved
performance spray of door tobias king
for more information through the car
lease a jeans of 14 pages and just kamp
area to the region which doesn't get to
ask
marc rich or that place you still collapse
offline ambiance king has  come get the
beginning of the end
julius nam ons bass lines that you think
of learning how to give you the boost
though the depth this is the gates
podcast where how is really my closet
weak possibly go wrong and more
cheating build robots and the poor
systems  and automated machine learning
the answer is in general
hjf lawyers network drive
soul sister always there hi in ise rinus
hello know you're thinking about
specifically for keeps you up at night
and my party signs you in the body
to help now will turn bernay's ran  ze
in robotics infographic guys
drones port of hong pastry dyslexia die
were critical alright looking for an
angry birds eye view mens classic mens
in die op in wide and not getting [ __ ]
green switch off guard enough space
flight
so the box can be isolated from you must
be reasonably almost in side holmes and in
other great for sale sky high in the
sky
and absolutly the good thing is the glacier
buddies video world and is in the
community  a throw realizes that you
can just go and fire walk with any
network castle
maybe legging items also
decisionmaking granny
right to this cute researchers right now
and how to be safely enforcement like
him and person in van de lakens green
force met lending at work closely with
for example the reinforcement learning
group and grabbed my reinforcement
learning group in new york city
and this is how jeff got and find who
that name is aaron gwin c was friend with
leggings of je station mekking
safe control he slept better known that
these efforts on goin  ' on and this also
used for example i nyssa in die put
working of mobile and tablet apple id
my working of pipeline debugging and
tricks and fairness and vie  wing and
parts of us are microsoft and the
community in general
zo at freelight people haibara work the
community site paris where everybody is
already so much water that week and you win
who or aramis another the prefer agent
if who not to make a contribution  to be
very realistic and all about highball it
was ground the teams that tumblr king
forward to you is like for example a
better i thinking about body
produces medical surgery
so the often that the system need i
run fast where all shot covering
decisions blythe li
designing steps wie dag doing that i
would be a word to make decisions which
will be very dangerous situations of
evernote dak amine dangerous pak you can
be blooming sitchin's wit also never
am doing right
en dakvlak de vast chooses app en app and
derby hair being week  brain design
with isabel
microsoft microsoft research 1st
place with spot tools in weapons
interests thematic penguins in that
neighborhood space between
regulated a  nd regulated is from seymour
talking about a and machine learning
the tesla by actors altair job to
have acces stil and bryan's for this
can you technology that my userform arne
various purposes or might not least in
a follow best practices yes coincidence is
the community thinking about  way you make
in that chair if there is in freddy
powerful to
jaap so that i have the bitrate name in
the research community
lucas oftentimes what happens is that who
won black molly siphon link
your blog something line gradually body wash
so my show that  dna technology
and racing the production of the primary
evening deploy
fit the plan wright and en fixed
convince others and van if it's not
comply or any means that you may be kept
seem to the big air af die write this
in the greek en shangri  -la Geef in reed
over bartex live interview hi black
services machine learning services and
white
en wat doen je doerebout things which a
beyond our control or right
week en right to link to  verify anymore
by reaches out there let's do it
definitively how model has been
sport
after the weekend expected true scenario
where all we have to do is
bibi them he presses own member this
was so credit card new apps were
in signal just the closet  of time or
that which is a pretty strong wind
of sharpened edges players ago
starter
spock think of this is just a miner
extension of natural history from right
lukkien of
en super ocampa type tech deck hey in the
bum everybody experiment inventive
archive about pin van  detail sorry
flashing exactly amber dc of this is
just en mind and extension of the
adoration
yes and had what is those spots
respect your af defense article susie
hair in pops imagazine a robot and also
picking over the word right now this
lot's of problems to be  silent drive there
is hello nina other my bae you can
medicines daryl and it says user to
their journey
lucy professionally bridge star wat
arian dep  pen depth who interested in
computer science in her bikes and harry
chandler microsoft research
ok wow freddy keepershort with the story
begins another item engineer inc oled
in new delhi
the indian tribe forgetting in
retirement skool is that is a very
tough
al india entrance exam and  then
depending upon the right you get ye go
get ye go go to good place so tight end
experiment check this that for a large
x-large hem en keep you do when
letters and that is kind of off dat youtube
aerolite today and occasionally keppens  is
off you get to call wedge
de jammed here is who you bore ok
hmm barbie kas the new everyting that
was already in the cart ricola min de
festool yes i'm
you you study and panache lek ok
contempt to do and stuff
and remember the  fast summer of the de
fakir of carnage [ __ ] man show of frans
witjes board so delicious week food does
something magical ground for my
en delicious hey hello two farmers bak I
snap symbol
another solid from na da  g was new and
not packed france but this is leak
young people do brasil few
kilograms china
yes at conferences of the younger
thats his idea some point the [ __ ] it
jack already a live show you like ok
via points do robotics angry bird
europe and japan
i take in this competition in the us king
your videos time between i just live
event in baker bart xprize and also a
vegetable garden to stand so is liking on three
internet was the side of online course
maria johanna
special in india have nutrition  not
scary this was nobody to teach robotics and
so it was absel
we then this was fun because castillo bake
in the base mine or together
18th mechanical engineering the pak my
budget nightwing use the light and
earth just a new one the software was and
there is  a leak rather then she would never
basketball can robotics
with let you guys what have a this because
i again in delhi
[ __ ] greetings from cm you on this copy
and that's not get this company car ipad
roboti  cs so weekend of baking meeting
white and who you lit the thing pdf
chips der eijk rebut
you don't care if i do not because she
actually new water bowl i swipe ikazia
coming right from simyo
and finishing is master his new
strike this company
je  must be pathcode de us and i was there
that day new place for you buy this
book for ashes and drink mouth of the us that
chance is not here yet
who can in fine diary little and
sangat milk is
solid or module bin x and resets  there and
then a another grafted en of mijn
cardio riding and cheaper the figure
arctic center at carnegie mellon en
de Nacht cadaques finish my masters nps
die der eijk kimberly in their fingers
and then back the us and that's how i
got stuck baby had to risk  from
english
fsc pure passion fire and ice and we want to go
to the smart is person in the room was
a familiar to the blog for he crossed
collecting and research and his name
google finish aps die is ninety-nine
few cents per sapiens and  three sets
as almost all big things in life it's
all portion fire and jazz rock the sticker
tribe and of the ups and downs and lucky
enough all too loud fantastic advisors
semi was a miracle for placemaking pms
her i al toriel jazz swing in the
messiah  messiah die
for the ferry singapore de nimar 100
aquino technology billion who
apple juice problems like us through many
problems to work on en diana die him yes
something i don't know about you have
and discretion and trams en help each
file character tretorn
defining moment  let your girl research
dead and game for en and i show you
between my food dah
oh my mother is yesterday professor in
india and growing up white port
zwingelaar place the casual big niet al
qaida but not least is frilec league
nature and everything was very good  at
swallowed krishna for there already knew
bilingues professor and never wanted to
do anything wit cis
infotec silicone baking mat all your input
flank basic calculus en gray the left
right
muslims stocking up to ping attention and
a half that was very boring and by a
sailor predominate member ate to the time
was in the atmosphere in perry sneaky and there
is a sector floor go do this sector
wings and keeper planning demo of them
over and  name is noise so as a
review and it's free fry my mother
one s aquina humanity club dress does
tough his mind economy crea libische
chooses in india
i'm an in-house mix living from
the mean this most weperen go and will
not make up and it's very
hot get actualia living wage atomic bonding is
professor listing india and yes because
science and engineering state in
their use you will make enough money
comperio image
but these always so partners are my
family this is a couple i  live for
you can be in english professor
a small world collette somewhere that
would work a great
leslie clothes and i find my last
tassel en trams en hoe an app gave big
research interests in the stars  fer
tape decisionmaking under a stern t yes
my loss now black bikini and terror
again decision dries the apps and bobby
makeup i did for life choices the
technique optimal decisions and their
future and hitec research jc the name
antivirus is going through the dog in iphone
what youtube biotechnology out
and is the porch lily trial for
becoming kodak what your goal is
pension to the fundamental right seemed
him never seen a great researchers who
doesn't care mastery about the
fundamentals like this language and you
know where to go
bench press for  van jack mullins device
id cookie budget neatly knockback goes
so
all other people ailaik waal and in this
calculus monolight it seems boring en
wagner
and arjuna i'm binck is with all of that
stuff and special if you were going to
be in the aquarium
but  it is super use for just right to
become very very kodak of the my chance
the rest can you ex care or myself and very
very warm
your respect now or the prestige university
and today glass and mac there from the
principles roof who and fold crew
especialy for the cooling
pair process is already wasp i the candidate
who has
through lies cronshaw i took as the course
i so in make what the rest or the
cilician the risks of the  mentally
who will make something good art or die
so successful xandar
february confused you will be good
mute depth no this is ben thomas find
thanks for coming from the podcast and
share everything great stories and your
great war
thank you adalar of yourself
[Music  ]
summer more but not to there the depth
dike with her researchers have in your
room but make decisions
so the microsoft account bottle racer
[Music]